my son has been successfully subdued so
I think this is a good time to learn
about the price to earnings ratio price
to earnings ratio price to earnings
ratio and a lot of times you'll hear
people talk about a stock's pde ratio
ptooie ratio and it's all the same thing
it's just a faster way of saying price
to earnings ratio so let's think about
the price to earnings ratio of the
company in question this widget company
that we've been this widget case study I
guess we could call it that we've been
dealing with let's say that the market
value we talked before that the book
value per share of this company is five
dollars because the book value of his
equity is five million dollars and their
five million share there's 1 million
shares so 5 million divided by 1 million
is 5 dollars but let's say that the
market price let's say that this is
widgets Inc and let's say it's it's its
ticker symbol is W I and C for widgets
Inc and its prices it's trading at let's
say it's trading at let me make up a
good number let's say it's trading at
$3.50 it's trading at $3.50 and then we
learned in the first video that a price
by itself doesn't tell us a whole lot so
how many shares are there we know
there's a million shares shares there's
1 million shares so the market cap or
what the market perceives the value of
this equity is the market capitalization
is these two numbers if we have a
million shares in each of them the
market is saying is worth 350 then the
company or the equity not the company
the equity of the company is worth
thirty five no three point five million
dollars so let me write it out three
three point five million dollars and all
right this is this is the market value
of the equity what the market thinks the
equity is worth so this is interesting
in our case the book value of the equity
was five million dollars
but the market is saying no no you know
I don't necessarily believe those
accountants maybe they're throwing some
stuff in here that's not really there so
we're going to where we are we say it's
only worth three and a half million
dollars in this case the the company is
trading at at a discount to its Book
value and well I won't go into detail on
that now but that's actually a fairly
unusual circumstance unless you're
unless people are very suspicious about
the accounting or the actual book value
of the company or if they think that
this is just a kind of a an asset that
is kind of I guess the best ways it's
it's it's useful life has been shortened
you know if you own a bunch of video
stores and all of a sudden and you know
you say I have 10 million dollars of
video stores and then the next day
someone makes you know on-demand video
is there all of a sudden you know maybe
your assets aren't worth what you
thought they were before but we'll talk
a lot more about that when we deal with
with real examples but in this case
our market cap is below our book value
and you can even look at just from the
price I said you know the price and tell
you much but it tells you a decent bit
if you think of things in per share
because we know that the book value per
share is 5 dollars the price per share
the market price per share is three
dollars and 50 so you could also say oh
it's trading at a discount to book now
what were the earnings of the company
well it was making 35 cents so let me
write this down
so it's earnings earnings was 350,000
dollars in 2008 and let's just say we're
looking this we're looking at this you
know from the vantage point that 2008
has happened this isn't like I'm at the
beginning of 2008 in and modeling and so
let's say we're looking at this in on
January 1 of 2009 and let's say the
company has already released its
earnings although that normally takes a
lot longer probably closer to you know
45 to 90 days but let's say they already
released their earnings so we say oh you
know that this company made $350,000 in
2008 2008 or another thing that you
might see a lot when you look at
companies is that this is the trailing
this is trailing 12 months earnings
you'll see this TTM sometimes because
when someone says earnings are those
earning
last year are those the earnings that
you're predicting for next year so this
is trailing 12 months earnings and if
you want to look at earnings per share
so earnings per share EPS is this number
divided by the number of shares was 35
cents so first just to learn what the
price to earnings ratio is let's just
calculate it and then we could talk
about what it actually means and and if
we have time we can have a discussion on
on why a company will might have a
higher or lower price to earnings ratio
and that discussion can actually get
quite involved but in this case you
literally just take the price of the
stock and you divide it by the earnings
per share so the price term let me
switch colors just to ease the monotony
the price to earnings ratio is equal to
the price so three dollars and 50
divided by the earnings per share
divided by 35 cents so in this case the
price to earnings ratio is 10 what does
that tell you well there's there's a
couple of ways to think about it one is
you could kind of flip this no one ever
talks about the earnings to price ratio
but that's an interesting thing to think
about because it connects it with a lot
of other financial concepts that are out
there so let's just this is not a this
is kind of a you know a Sal special
ratio but it's it's a it's a useful one
to think about the earnings to price
ratio is just the inverse of this 0.35 -
350 which is equal to one tenth or ten
10% and so a way to think about it is is
if if your cut if you're paying 3.50 per
share for this company and let's say the
company next year so this was their
earnings this is trailing 12 months
earnings but let's say this company for
whatever reason it's a really stable
company it's doing the same thing every
year it's not growing it's not shrinking
let's say that not only is this the
trailing 12 months earnings but this is
also actually I'll introduce terminology
right here so this is trailing 12 months
you could also have forward earnings
forward earnings what our forward
earnings you could probably guess the
earnings I just said this is actually
what happened to the company this was
the earnings of the company last year or
the last
month forward earnings are you know
there's a bunch of guys with MBAs and
CFA is working for the we're working for
the banks and they write research
reports and they model the company they
meet with the company they analyze the
industry and if they're good analysts
they'll come up with a number they'll
say you know what I think this company
is going to make well they might say I
think this company's not going to change
it's such a super stable business
they're going to make 35 cents in 2009
as well as well so in this case this
would be the forward earnings and
usually if it's a well followed company
there might be ten or fifteen or twenty
analysts and what they do is they
average out all of the numbers from all
of those analysts and then if the
average is to say 35 cents they'll call
this the consensus so the consensus is
just the average of all of the sell-side
analysts out there and I'll maybe I
should do a whole video on what
sell-side means but since I said the
word I'll tell you right now sell-side
are like the investment banks and the
research houses and the reason why
they're the sell-side is because they're
always selling you stuff they're selling
you stocks they're brokering
transactions they write these research
reports because they want to go to
institutional investors or people who
have their brokerage accounts with these
banks and essentially sell them stock
say hey you should buy widgets Inc
because it's only trading at a price to
earnings at 10 and we really like it
it's much better than buying Treasury
bonds right now because you're making
more money on it you're making 10
percent and that's just to connect the
dots
you know priced earnings of 10 if it's
stable you're making every year the
equity will be growing at least or this
coming year it'll grow by 10% and that's
better than what you get on a Treasury
bonds so that's what sell side means buy
side so a sell side analysts is someone
who publishes these reports a buy side
analysts is someone who works for a
hedge fund or works for fidelity in a
mutual fund or works for an endowment or
pension someplace and they're managing
other people's money and they're trying
to figure out if these analysts make you
know if they can believe what's
happening so they're going to do their
own analysis so that's what the buy side
is those are the people who are actually
managing money in deciding what they
want to invest the money and the sell
side are the people who do analysis
say hey do to my analysis isn't this a
good stock don't you want to buy or sell
this stock so fair enough that was a bit
of a a diversion but anyway going back
to price to earnings we calculated the
price to earnings it was 10 but I reason
wanted to do earnings to prices because
it connects it back to things like yield
and interest and and you know like if I
have a you know I could do a price to
earnings on my bank account let's say in
my bank account I have let's say in my
bank account I have $100 so this is a
diversion right here so bank account
bank account so let's say I have $100 in
my bank account and over a year I make 2
percent interest let's say it's
guaranteed 2 percent maybe it's in a CD
so I have 102 dollars at the end of the
year this 2% were my earnings right so I
made 2 dollars over earnings two dollars
or earnings so the way to think about a
bank account is well how much do I pay
for that bank account well I paid well
in this case I paid $100 for the bank
account so the price would be $100 and
the earnings on the bank account in that
year were $2.00 so as a price to
earnings of 50 price to earnings of 50
or if you do the earnings to price if
you do 2 dollars over $100 you get 2
percent which is normally how we think
about bank accounts we say oh I'm making
2 percent interest on that bank account
now this actually leads to a very
interesting question if a bank account
only gives me 2 percent on my money and
this company is arguably giving me
assuming that it's stable and I believe
the consents is giving me 10 percent on
the money why would I hold why would I
even hold this bank account why would I
just pour all of my money why am I
willing to pay a higher price to
earnings for the bank account than I am
for this company right and I think you
already get the sense that the lower the
price to earnings all else equal and
that's a big thing all else equal the
lower the price to earnings you're
paying less for something you want to
have a lower price to earnings ratio for
the same asset because you're getting
the same earnings for lower price but
when you lower the
price-to-earnings you are increasing the
earnings to price right so you would
increase your yield right you want to
maximize this number but I'll finish
this video with with the kind of a basic
question why would someone ever keep
their money in the bank at 2% or at a
price to earnings of 50 when they could
get you know when they could have a
price to earnings of 10 with widgets Inc
and the answer is because this is very
uncertain who knows what happens with
the widgets Inc maybe all of these guys
were you know maybe this is a big Ponzi
scheme I mean not that you know most
companies in this country aren't and
that's another thing to talk about is
country risk because we have even though
you've you know you're probably
suspicious of them now the US has some
of the most transparent companies with
some of the best accounting standards if
this was in you know I don't want to I
don't want to state any countries
because people all over the world
listened to these videos but if it were
a country with less solid accounting
standards you like May they could might
they might be making up all of their
numbers so I don't trust it or you might
say you know what widgets Inc their
business is just very even though the
analysts are saying this the analysts
are saying that it's it's you know 30
they're going to make 35 cents this this
coming year you might say you know what
I don't believe that I think there's
actually a lot of risk in widgets Inc
that that these that there's actually
more volatility here than anyone gives
credit for and they might go into
business there's a there's a strong
competitor there's a lot of risk
involved and the other thing is even if
you don't think there's risk even if you
think that people are always going to
that this company's going to make 35
cents forever the other reason why you
might want prefer to have a bank account
over widgets Inc is because you're
guaranteed to get 102 dollars back back
for your bank account at the end of the
year if you want it assuming this was a
CD with a one-year with a one-year
duration you'll get your hundred you're
guaranteed to get your hundred and two
dollars back especially if it's FDIC
insured but in this in this case even
though the earnings might be the same
something horrible might happen to the
markets and everyone just dumps their
stock money flows just run outside of
markets and for whatever reason people
get scared and the price could go down a
lot from 350 it could be very very
volatile and and this thing might you
know maybe the price goes from 350 maybe
it goes to a dollar 75 a year later
which it seems like a really good deal
because now the price to earnings is a
dollar seventy-five divided by 35 would
now be would now be a five price
earnings but this could happen I mean
companies go from a 10 to a 5 price to
earnings and their of a sudden if you
want that money if you need that money a
year later you've lost half of it so
there's some volatility in the price
even though you're assuming that the
earnings are stable so that's a little
bit of a taste of of why the you know
someone might realistically in this case
pay a higher price to earnings for
safety safety because you know that this
earnings stream is guaranteed and
liquidity liquidity because you know
you're going to get your money back that
you're going to be able to essentially
sell your bank account and get cash for
it and you know that it's going to be a
hundred dollars that there's no
volatility in price well in this case
you're not uncertain about the earnings
stream you're uncertain about what the
market will be willing to value it a
year later and frankly you aren't you
might be one uncertain about liquidity
in general maybe this is a really small
company not a lot of people trade in it
and you might not even be able to find
anyone to buy it
a year later I mean that you know the
epitome of an illiquid asset is of maybe
a really expensive a twenty million
dollar house even though it might be
worth twenty million dollars a year
later you might not just feel there are
only so many people who can afford a
twenty million dollar house so it's an
illiquid asset anyway I wanted to leave
you there in the next video we'll go
into more depth on price to earnings
ratio and and think about things like
growth and stability and whatnot